over to reed international making
changes in the name of pedestrian safety
they're putting in hundreds of those
bollards at the terminal one departures
area hector mejia is there live at the
airport hector we're told maybe some
delays for passenger drop-offs that
could last a year
that's true that's how long this project
has taken good morning to you nate so
this is a 4.9 million dollar project it
just started this week and that means
that crews will be taking out two
traffic lanes this morning we're in
front of the terminal one departures
area where you see some passengers
arriving for early flights this morning
joining us live we have joe rachel
spokesperson here at harry reid
international airport to talk to us
about the changes and why is this so
exciting good morning to you good
morning yeah you know as you mentioned
this project is an opportunity here for
us to install safety bollards here along
the terminal 1 departures curb that's
good safety for pedestrians it's good
for structural security we're also using
this opportunity to as we have to dig up
the concrete to replace it with new
durable sustainable material and do some
utility upgrades as well so you guys are
going beyond the bollards and on the
last half hour we could hear all of the
construction going on sounds like
they're kind of taking a bit of a break
but they're still out there working hard
yeah absolutely they're you know
prepping that concrete to be able to
remove it and get this process started
all right so in terms of the traffic
delays especially during those peak
travel times let's say a holiday coming
around the corner we have plenty of
those coming up this year uh what should
we all prepare for you know we just want
people to give themselves a little bit
of extra time um you know we are losing
two lanes where that work is occurring
and it's moving along in seven phases
correct this project done in seven
phases we're gonna lose uh where that
work is happening we're going to lose
two lanes and so we expect it to
compound some of those busier times so
give yourself a little bit of extra time
and also use the adjacent middle lanes
to to drop off passengers fantastic
thank you so much so again this project
just started this week and we can see
here some passengers arriving again this
is what everyone can expect uh
construction again until 2023 not only
safety ballers but a brand new pavement
in front of the terminal one departures
area reporting live hector mejia live
local now all right hector thank you
very much you could also sneak over to
the short term parking where you have
the pickup and just drop off there and
walk across the little alleyway there
might be a sneaky way around